okay we're here with Ranveer tell us a
little bit about who you are and what
you do at Microsoft Research yeah I'm a
senior researcher at Microsoft Research
in the mobility and networking research
group I've been at Microsoft research
for about eight and a half years now
great and you work in Wi-Fi with with
white space tell us a little bit what is
white space for people who might not
know to start with white spaces refers
to so in the technical term white space
as well anything which is blank is white
space in the context of frequencies
Wireless frequencies any unused spectrum
is what we refer to as white spaces so
to give you a bigger overview a broader
overview of what the problem is and how
it came about why is this an important
problem so back in 2004 the FCC issued a
notice of proposal for rulemaking saying
hey this wireless spectrum is really
occupied there this TB bans not all of
it is in use all the time can we
opportunistically use the unused TB
spectrum for wireless communication or
Wi-Fi light communication and since then
I joined in 2005 and since then I have
been looking at this problem
investigating and seeing okay so the
wireless spectrum is occupied
but portions of it are actually not in
use first we wanted to quantify how much
of the spectrum is not in use then
finding that out we built a protocol
which we called white Phi for Wi-Fi over
the white spaces where we took a
commodity Wi-Fi chipset built the extra
hardware around it and sure that you
could operate in these empty TV
frequencies without actually interfering
with TV transmissions when we started
doing it back in 2005 there was nothing
right it was all just a vague idea that
how would you go about doing it when
when we started the first step we took
was actually built the first piece piece
of hardware now there are two approaches
to go about doing it we could actually
sense the medium you could find out that
is you could have a separate chip on
your device imagine your phone with a
separate chip what the chip is doing is
it's sensing the medium to see whether
that by medium I mean the entire RF
frequencies to find out which channel is
available which channel is not so we
build the system around it that is that
would sense the medium it would send
that information up to the operating
system we built a platform on Windows
the operating system would then instruct
the radio to operate to send signals in
the empty TV channels that was how we
started then the next day question we
asked was okay from a scientific
perspective we've shown how you could
achieve this kind of we call it dynamic
spectrum access how would it actually
work in practice how would you get it in
the hands of people that's when we
realize having the separate chip on the
phone would make it more costly would
consume more power it wouldn't really
work so then from 2008 onwards through
2010 we actually built another system we
built a system that spanned all of
Microsoft campus we deployed two
whitespace space stations one on
building 112 one and building 18 and we
and then we showed that you could
actually and then we used instead of a
chip on the device we used a web service
to tell you at that location what
channels are available so is using the
spectrum different from what we do now
with like my router at home yeah let's
tell us about the system that you had to
architect for this right so that's a
good question so before I go there first
have me tell you what are the benefits
of even using the white spaces why are
we even looking at this new spectrum
there are two main reasons why we are
looking at the spectrum one is you might
be hearing all this news going around of
well there's a spectrum crunch we don't
have enough spectrum well we do have a
lot of spectrum it's just that it's not
available for us to use right for
example TV was a classic example where
there are these TV channels it's been
allocated to TV but it's not in use so
if we can start using it so this is a
new paradigm right so using this is the
first point that is white-spaces gives
you additional spectrum for the wireless
data demand that's happening right now
the second benefit of the TV white
spaces is range that is because it's in
the lower frequencies you can get four
times the distance at the same transmit
power then you can get over Wi-Fi over
2.4 gigahertz over five gigahertz that's
1111 n these are the terms that you hear
so compared to a standard 11g system
we've done experiments so you could
easily get four times the distance in
free space that is if there was no
obstructions I could get I could so for
example your Wi-Fi router at home you
can access it at four times the distance
and
can right now that is in free spaces for
times when you have buildings and
obstructions it's much more in fact that
was the example I was telling you before
that if you had to cover all of
Microsoft campus over here which is one
mile by one mile using Wi-Fi you would
need hundreds of Wi-Fi routers with the
white spaces what we showed this with
just two base stations one or building
112 and 118 we could blanket all of
campus you did some work with the Xbox
one team tell us about that yeah so I'm
a wireless guy right the reason I joined
Microsoft research rather than going to
academia was because I wanted to ship
the work I did as part of my internship
here I've had lots of interactions with
the product teams over the years but the
Xbox one came out came up as a unique
opportunity where it came as a the Xbox
team approached me and they said hey we
have this interesting problem we wanted
to design a new wireless protocol from
your controller to the console and you
might think well these are just button
clicks why do we need a fancy protocol
but well these button clicks are
important because you need a predictable
latency for these button clicks if you
look at the Xbox one controller it
supports chat you can have a headset
attached to the controller
once you have chat traffic you have high
throughput traffic which also needs
latency guarantees so if you look at the
entire research that has happened or
even the way in the industry is moved
about all the press that is going out
that is going around about Wireless the
new innovations and Wireless everyone's
talking about how do you push more bits
in the air how do you get more capacity
from your wireless network no one's
really talking about how do you get this
extra capacity while getting a
predictable latency and and what are the
the impacts that it has on latency what
are the differences from what we had
before right so earlier earlier systems
just couldn't achieve the throughput
while maintaining the latency so there's
no system right now the Xbox 360 the ps3
or the ps4 none of them have this
capability to get the throughput and the
latency that we can achieve with the
Xbox one so we can support several types
of traffic classes different traffic
classes each with their own throughput
and latency guarantees and we are able
to achieve that those guarantees both in
terms of throughput and latency which no
other system can
right now so the way we achieved that
well there were lots of innovation
happening starting from the wireless
layer where we were looking at fading
for example to define fading what I mean
is if I send a signal to you the signal
that you're getting well people say that
there's an odd term called RSS I
received signal strength if I'm sending
a signal I'm transmitting some signal to
you you're not going to receive it at
the same power you see a lot of
fluctuation in the power that you see
and the fluctuation that you see is
pretty significant and for certain
periods of time this is called feeding
and we had to counter it this is just
one of the problems that we had to
counter that is even when the signal
gets low how do you make sure that my
packets still get tea right then there
are many other issues for example what
modulation scheme should I use so if I'm
sending a packet to you I just don't
send the packets one zeros I modulate it
the way I send it over the medium is I
encode the entire packet before sending
it out and the the lower the modulation
scheme the lower throughput I get but
the more robust it is now these are
again schemes that we had to play with
we had to ensure that you're sending it
with the right modulation so that the
packet gets through to the other side
within the deadline that we had to meet
for that kind of traffic I know one of
your focus is in energy efficiency talk
about the challenges that you have with
maintaining long battery life when using
a radio yeah so well buttery is a big
pain point for nearly everyone who has a
mobile phone or a tablet right or even a
laptop for that matter so we started
this work back in 2010 where I was
essentially leading a virtual team
inside MSR with a bunch of researchers
all over the world all the labs and
spanning areas of expertise from
hardware to security to software to just
software engineering to programming
languages networking systems Hardware
sensors everything and we came up we had
a mission the mission was of her group
was hey let's try to achieve a battery
life of one week without charge for a
phone that is you shouldn't need to plug
your phone for one week now that was
it's an ambitious mission the mission
statements have to be a mish
so that is what we set out with and with
that we are looking at all the different
parts of the stack starting from
batteries that is looking at chemistry
of batteries trying to investigate new
chemistry's that are out there we
talking to a bunch of startups trying to
see would a new type of battery make
sense
we're also looking at the operating
system how should the operating system
actually use the characteristics of the
battery how should so and also be
looking at techniques within the OS for
example the scheduling algorithms how
should they be energy aware and also a
lot of application layer stuff as well
so right from the battery to the OS to
the applications we are looking at all
across the stack for example we wrote a
paper which was in mobi says 2012 I
think which was around email energy
efficiency how much energy does email
conceal and you'd be surprised to know
that each incoming email when your
screen is off consumes a lot of power it
turns on the radio right where your
screen is off I'm getting incoming
emails I enable push every incoming
email turns the radio on once the radio
is on it doesn't immediately go back to
sleep when the when the email is
received in fact once I receive the
email the radio turns on the processor
turns on as well because that's where
all the emails are stored it needs to
receive the email do the processing and
even the radio itself it's it has
something called at pier time every time
it wakes up even after your transactions
are done it'll be awake for a few
seconds in some cases more than 10
seconds doing nothing it's just in the
on state and in the on state it consumes
a lot of power of the order of a watt in
some of our measurements with LD so
these are the kind of things which we've
investigated and we are looking at all
the different components starting from
your CPU your radio your display your
disk storages other memory how do you
reduce the energy consumed by each of
these components so a work is spanning
all the different parts of the stack and
that that's the thing with energy
there's no I don't think there's a
silver bullet we need to attack it from
all possible corners just try to reduce
the energy consumption in every
component and together we will see a lot
of benefits yeah one of the first
projects that you worked on Microsoft
was virtual Wi-Fi and tell us about that
what is it and it had quite a lot of
downloads what do people use it for
yeah that's an interesting question
because it's it started in 2002 this
work when I was an intern here Victor
asked me this question he can you enable
ad hoc mode and so that time it was ad
hoc was peer-to-peer mode and
infrastructure mode at the same time the
vision was the following right now you
click on your wireless icon you select
one network to connect it the vision was
what if he could select multiple of them
and say he connect me to all of them and
that had that can have many benefits one
of them is they could get more capacity
I just aggregate more throughput right
I'll get more so this was one of the use
cases that people are using it for so I
built the software around it this was
for Windows XP it had a kernel driver
people had to I wrote the kind of driver
which people had to install it tried the
software service and it would allow it
would allow you to do that you could be
connected to multiple networks at the
same time now when we came here of
course there wasn't much interested in
at that time to ship it because it was
too ambitious shipping a kernel level
driver is not easy coming from research
now so we ended up publishing the the
sources and the binaries for download
and then we got lots of downloads we got
right now I think it's 250,000 plus
count and people use it a lot of people
who use it are for in enterprise
networks they use it for kind of
secluding people to different so they
have different Wi-Fi networks for
different purposes and people have
different roles so they will be able to
connect with different networks at the
same time so we got a lot of good
reviews around the software and people
who are using it but what shipped in
Windows 7 was a much mini version of our
vision that we had well to allow you to
connect to all the networks what ships
in Windows 7 and beyond is the ability
for a user to be a Wi-Fi access point
and be connected to another network at
the same time so that functionality is
that it was called soft DP and it
evolved into a Wi-Fi standard called
Wi-Fi direct
so Wi-Fi direct right now its shipping
in Windows 8 Windows 8.1 all the devices
Android and iPhone devices are shipping
it it's built on top of virtual Wi-Fi
and what's next on the horizon as far as
research goes well as far as Wi-Fi and
and an energy efficiency right so energy
efficiency we are not there to our
mission right
and there we are investigating a lot of
different things in energy I'll tell you
two different big bets we have taken an
energy and we are pushing hard on both
this is cross group effort again both of
them one is off load that is so as I
said right we want to get to 7x energy
gains how do we get there all the minor
tweaks well it's going to give us a
little bit of benefit it's not going to
get us to 7x a week without charge so
how do we get there one big bet as I
said is offload that is offload your we
want to offload applications processes
that are running on the main device to
either a low-power core instead of
running it on the entire heavyweight
core or the CPU and everything else on
your device there's a low park or on
which it could run or it could be
uploaded to the cloud rather than so
your device can be completely asleep
when all the processing is being run in
the cloud
the second big bet we have which we are
actively investigating is around battery
technologies and how the OS should use
it so there we are we have some ideas
around if you had many batteries how
should you actually intelligently use
them and even if you have a single
battery right now the OS or the entire
system treats the battery as this isn't
energy reservoir while it tree while the
while the OS very fine it it manages the
CPU memory and disk and network in a
very fine-grained way but it doesn't
really care much about the battery and
we believe that with a tight integration
and if the OS is more battery aware of
the battery characteristics things such
as how old is my battery what's the
temperature around me how what is the
workload going to be how many high power
that's when when are we gettin high high
workload high current workloads whenever
getting low current workloads and so on
so this is another active piece of work
in in the energy space so if you're
using this white space how can you
assure that you're not going to step on
other frequencies that are actually
being used right so here when we started
this work one of the things was well how
do you determine which part of the
spectrum is not in use we need to do
that very accurately and the second
thing is when we transmit we need to
make sure that any of the transmissions
don't cause interference to the primary
users of the
spectrum in this case the TV so when we
were doing that we build a system which
was able to do that using both we first
showed it using sensing the second step
we showed it using the geolocation web
service where you did not need this
extra chipset well thank you so much for
talking to us today yeah thanks